hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
arthur schopenhauer in part three of his
treaties on the basis of morality is
going to focus
on the relationship between compassion
mitt lied
and justice galactic kite in chapter 17
which is quite long and we're going to
look here at just some of the
first aspects that he treats and then
put the others off for additional
discussions
and so he begins chapter 17 by saying if
we consider more closely the occurrence
of compassion which was shown to be the
primary ethical phenomenon
it is at once evident there's two
clearly
separate degrees with it wherein another
suffering can directly become my motive
in other words can determine me to do or
admit to do something so compassion mid
light should be our
motive our incentive the thing that is
fundamentally driving us and this is
going to bring us into
conflict you could say
with other motives that we do have by
virtue of being human beings
and by virtue of our own
unique expression of human nature so
what are these two degrees these are
what are going to yield us the two
virtues as he's going to call them
so
they counteract
egoistic or malicious motives that is
what we're going to be calling
justice right
and we're driven quite often if not by
malicious motives many of us do have
those we're definitely driven by
egoistic ones and so we have to say no
to them we have to prioritize over them
in some ways
and then
we can have another person's suffering
becoming something that incites us to
active help and this is going to lead to
philanthropy
or to loving kindness mention liba
literally the love of humankind
so these are both going to be central
and they're both about
the suffering of others
he says that compassion prevents me from
causing suffering to
another and hence from becoming myself
the cause
of another's
pain
so
he's going to talk quite a bit about
these these two and
he's also going to tell us that the
separation between so-called duties of
law and duties of virtue
more correctly between justice and
philanthropy
results here entirely of itself and
testifies to the correctness of the
principle
it is the natural unmistakable and sharp
boundary between the negative and the
positive between doing no injury
and helping and he says the terms that
we've used before duties of law and
duties of virtue also called duties of
love or imperfect virtues
these are not the best way to talk about
it instead
we want to think about the negative as
being the virtue the
you know actual disposition
of justice and we want to think of the
positive as the disposition of
philanthropy or
loving kindness now turning our
direction to justice itself and we'll
come back to this distinction in just a
minute in a different respect
looking at justice itself he tells us
that we as
human beings tend to be inclined to
injustice and violence
why
because our needs our desires our anger
and hatred immediately enter
consciousness and thus have the right of
first occupancy right so
we're aware of our own desires we're
aware of our own drives and stuff like
that
when it comes to other people who we can
cause to suffer we are going to be
aware of that you could say
secondhand
tells us that we
um
the sufferings of others that are caused
by our injustice and violence enter
consciousness
merely on the secondary path of the
representation and only through
experience thus indirectly so you know
to take an example
we say something that is deeply hurtful
to another person and we don't realize
at we don't realize it at the time that
we're saying that it's going to be so
hurtful to the other person and then we
see for example the pained look on their
face or their complaints or crying or
something like that and we're like oh i
shouldn't have done that well
that
is is something that we have to become
aware of piecemeal you could say and we
can never be completely sure somebody
could be faking it whereas you know we
ourselves were conscious of our own
suffering uh when it happens right
although we can hide that from ourselves
as well
and so how does justice work
he tells us
that the first degree of the effect of
compassion
if we actually are feeling it
is that it opposes and impedes those
sufferings i
intend to cause others by my inherent
moral forces it calls out to me stop it
stands before the other man like a
bulwark prompting him from the injury
that my egoism or malice would otherwise
uh urge me to do so you know again to go
back to the example of insulting
somebody so now you know
that saying a certain thing to them is
going to be hurtful insulting perhaps
humiliating and you're still
wanting to do it maybe out of egoistic
motives you want to put them down so you
can be higher up or you want to
neutralize them in some way
or it could be pure malice you just want
to hurt them for the sake of hurting
them are you driven by envy or something
like that that
schopenhauer is willing to call
an effect of malice well
the
the
compassion stands in the way
through this mode of justice saying
don't cause that suffering and it has to
do that precisely because you do
intend to cause the suffering it doesn't
have to say it if you don't intend it
now he goes on a little bit
further
and he says if my disposition is
susceptible to compassion up to that
degree
it will restrain me
wherever and whenever i feel inclined to
use another sufferings
as a means to the attainment of my ends
it is immaterial whether that suffering
is instantaneous or comes later whether
it's direct or indirect affected or
affected through intermediate
links and so he gives some prime
examples here
i will
just as little sees another person's
property as i shall their person i shall
cause him just as little mental
suffering as bodily i shall therefore
refrain not only from every physical
injury but the infliction of mental
suffering through mortification alarm
annoyance or slander the same compassion
will prevent me from seeking to satisfy
my desires at the expense of women's
happiness or from seducing another man's
wife or even from ruining youths morally
and physically by tempting them to
commit pedophilia you won't be
engaging in sexual improprieties that
are you know damaging to other people to
their structures of relationships
perhaps to their own psychological
development so
this is very important
can compassion do this
all the time
well no and in many cases what we need
is something a bit more consolidated
this is part of why we can talk about a
virtue
of justice so schopenhauer brings up
rational reflection he says rational
reflection on this idea of not harming
others
raises noble dispositions to the firm
resolution
grasped once for all
of respecting the rights of everyone
never allowing themselves to encroach on
them keeping themselves free from the
self-reproach of being the cause of
another's suffering so
we human beings can in fact be just to
each other not just by being provoked
immediately by feeling or
compassion but by consolidating it into
a disposition
raising the noble disposition to
resolutions right
so he talks about how principles
and abstract knowledge
they are not the original source or
first foundation of morality
but they are as he says indispensable
to a moral course of life and he's got
this interesting metaphor here they are
the receptacle or reservoir which stores
the habit of mind which is sprung from
the fount of all morality a habit of
mind that does not flow at every moment
but when the occasion for its
application arises flows along the
proper
channel so we've got you know you could
say affectivity and we've also got the
use of our intellect in a practical way
so
principles and abstract knowledge are
indispensable and he goes on a little
bit further and he says
self-control
is the steadfast adherence to
an observance of principles in spite
of the motives that act against them so
self-control is really
central there as well
he talks about
compassion
sometimes coming forth in what he calls
individual cases so in particular
circumstances and that
has to happen occasionally
why
because what rational reflection yields
for us
is not always going to be
as helpful as we'd like he says in
individual cases the established maxim
of justice shows signs of breaking down
no motive is more effective for
supporting it and putting new life into
just resolutions
than that drawn from the fountain head
itself so
when we want to make sure that our just
resolutions which are part of the
rational reflection is working we need
to go back to the fountain the origin
itself of the motive
of compassion
and so he says that
this holds good not merely where it's a
question of personal injury but also
where damage to property is concerned
and here he's got some other good
examples as well
nothing will bring us back to the path
of justice so readily
as the mental picture of the trouble
grief and lamentation of the
loser of property right thus is that
this truth is felt it often happens the
public appeal for the return of lost
money has the assurance added that the
loser is poor a domestic servant and so
on so when we think about
how somebody else is going to be
negatively affected then we can feel
compassion for them so there's a very
interesting dialectic here between
rationality and compassion going on in
this now i mentioned we would come back
to this distinction between
justice and philanthropy because we
should take notice of something
kind of bone-headed that schopenhauer
says in this
you know like many other
male philosophers you get the idea that
schopenhauer doesn't understand
women very well and is willing to make
some super sweeping generalizations
about the differences between men and
women so what he says here is
we can find the reason why women are as
a rule inferior to men in the virtue of
justice and thus of uprightness and
conscientiousness
and it says by you know contrast they
surpass men in the virtue of
philanthropy or loving-kindness and why
is this the case he says the weakness of
their reasoning faculty they're less
capable than men of understanding and
stricken to you
sticking to universal principles and
taking them as a guide
very debatable and we're schopenhauer
brought here in the present i think he
would probably have to revise his
mistaken assumptions
on the other hand he says that
philanthropy or loving kindness
the origin of this is in most cases
intuitive and therefore appeals directly
to compassion to which women are
decidedly
more easily susceptible and then he says
for women only what is intuitive present
and immediately real truly exists what
is knowable only by means of concepts
what is remote absent past or future
cannot really be grasped by them so
justice is more masculine virtue loving
kindness more a
feminine
we can certainly accept that there are
differences in types among people
without pegging them
necessarily to gender differences which
might be much more cultural or just
based in poor empirical observation on
schopenhauer's part now going on with
this
schopenhauer is going to bring up one
more
really key point
he says that
these observations will clarify that
however little this appears to be the
case at first sight
justice
as a genuine voluntary virtue certainly
has its origin in compassion now those
are both very important qualifying terms
genuine actual justice real justice
as a virtue and voluntary something that
we
choose for its own sake right valuing
is rooted in compassion
it's rooted in compassion in both a
direct way and an indirect way
and then he goes on and he says
if however
anyone should suppose this soil to poor
and meager for the that great and really
cardinal virtue to be capable of taking
root he should bear in mind the above
remarks and remember how small is the
amount of genuine
voluntary unselfish and plain justice to
be found among human beings
he should note how justice always occurs
as a surprising exception and its
counterfeit the justice
that rests on mere prudence and is
everywhere advertised is related to it
in quality and quantity as copper is to
gold so
taking a little
you know hint from plato's symposium he
says i would like to call counterfeit
justice de cayoscinae
right so the vulgar the the common kind
of justice and then contrast to that the
genuine as dikaiosunae urania heavenly
justice right this is something that
that pausanius
does within
the symposium in his speech speaking
about justice and love
so
genuine voluntary
justice
it's going to be rare but it exists and
then throughout the world we see a
facsimile of justice a counterfeit of
justice something that is as copper is
to gold now copper is still useful right
this is not as good as gold
and we can say that the justice that is
done by people out of egoistic motives
rather than out of the motive of
compassion
it isn't without utility or
helpfulness or
you know
a rule within society of keeping us from
degenerating into a war of all against
all
but it is not the virtue of justice it's
just the appearance of it so we see that
compassion
and justice are going to be connected up
with each other
in rather
complex and robust ways
you